で あの これからあの いわゆる完璧主義という言葉をテーマにして
お釈迦様が我々は何をおっしゃいましたかということについてお話をさせていただきます
で あの いくらかお釈迦様
我々に言おうと おっしゃろうとしているところは
この説明書の文章の中にも入ってあっただろうと思います
ですから まああまり難しく私に喋ることはそれほどはないんです
で 大体どんな人間でも
心の中では完璧になりたいとかね
で 完全にやることは完全にしたいという気持ちはあるんですよ
ない人はほとんどないぐらい
それでたまたまいるんですね
何一つも完璧にも正しくしようとしないで
まあする人々もいますよ
何やっても中途半端で
途中でやめたり あるいは物事も変えて違うことをしたりしてしまったり
まあどちらでも何者かとわからないぐらいの性格の人もいますけどね
仕事をしたっても ゴロゴロゴロゴロ変わったりするし
勉強にしたっても こういうことをちょっとやったり
他のことをちょっとやったりとか
結局最終的には何も得てないという
まあそういう人もいるんだけど
それはまあ大勢じゃないんですよ
まあ数少ないんですね
ですから このまあ そういう何人かがね
大体どんな社会でも 大体まあ 100人
200人ぐらい人々を調べると
一人ぐらいはそうやってこの中途半端な生き方で生きている人々もいますけど
で 他の方々は真面目に普通に生活したい方々っていうのは
大勢の人々なんですね
そういう方々は大体 やることはしっかりやりたいと
しっかりなさりたいとという気持ちはあるんです
それは一般的で普通なんですよ
しっかりやりたくないと思うならば
まあそれはちょっとした病気みたいなもので
数少ない人々だから それほど我々気にしなくてもいいんです
で そこで問題は そういう問題児のことではなくて
我々のことなんですよ
完璧 完全主義を持っている我々のことなんですね
だからどういうことかというと
物事を完全にうまく成功したいんですが
なかなかうまくいかない
いろいろトラブルが起きたりする
で 問題も起きたりする
そういう一般的な真面目な方々の間の問題なんですね
今日のタイトルは で あの完璧主義という言葉がね
この説明の章にあったように
まあ良い面も悪い面も見ようとすれば見られます
大体 これから悪い面だけで考えていますけど
で 物事を完璧にしようしようと思っているところでうまくいかないと
かなりストレスになっちゃうんですよ
かなり自己嫌悪になっちゃうんですね
悔しくなっちゃうんですね
それで自信がなくなってしまっちゃうんですよ
あまりにも失敗すると
で そうするとそれはいいことではありません
完璧に何かしようとしたところで失敗しましたと
また頑張ったところでまた失敗しましたと
そういうことで自信がなくなってしまって
もうやる気がなくなってしまって
で 問題 さらに問題が起きたりする
暗くなってしまっちゃう
そういうとこはまあ 我々はいくらか考えてみましょう
で ある法句経でお釈迦様はこういう偈がおっしゃいましたけど
ナチャーフナチャバビッサティナチャエータラヒヴィッジャティ
エーカンタンニンディトウポウソ
エーカンタンワパサンシト
今日は書くことはちょっとできませんですけど
ネチャアフいたこともない
ネチャバヴィッサティ
これからもいるわけではありません
ネチャエータラヒヴィッジャティ
今もいませんと 誰ですか？エーカンタンニンディトウポウソ
極端に非難するべき人
完全に悪いだと 非難するべき人っていうのは昔もいなかったし
これからも現れないし
今もいませんと もう一つ
エーカンタンパサンシト
完全に素晴らしいんだと
完璧だと褒めるべき 極端に褒めるべき人もいませんと
だからその中にお釈迦様の言葉の中にちゃんと全てまとめてあると思いますね
昔もいなかった 今もいない
これからも現れようともしない
どういう人かというと
極端に悪い人やという極悪人もいませんし
もう完璧に素晴らしい人やという完全な人もいませんと
ということで お釈迦様は何をおっしゃいますかというと
まあ人間というのは誰でもそこそこいるんだということなんですよ
誰一人も完璧ではありませんと
だからといってダメだと
極悪人だと ゴミだと 何の役にも立たないんだと思って人を捨てることもできませんと
そういう人はいませんと
極端な人が いるのはみんな真ん中なんですよ
だから前申し上げた この中途半端なろくに仕事もしないで
ゴロゴロ仕事を変わったり
いろんなことをやっている人々にしても
もうちゃんと叱って指導すれば
強引にでもね まあなんとか人生は明るくすることはできるんだからね
ですから この 両極端には人間はいませんということはまず理解してほしい
その四行のお釈迦様のその言葉を理解してもらうと
正しく理解してもらうと
我々に何が役に立ちますかと
我々には まず私が申し上げたいのは
落ち着くことできるんですよ
まあみんな不完全だよと
みんなまあそこそこだよと
そういうお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
この石に彫るような感じで心に彫ってもらいたいんですよ
決して忘れてはいけないんですよ
すぐ忘れちゃうんですよ
すぐ忘れて 大体自分のことを棚上げにして
他人から完璧なことを認めようとする
要求する 他人がちょっとでもミスを犯しちゃったら
それは全然認めない こちらすごく苛立ちを感じる
怒ったり怒鳴ったりする
非難したりする そこで心の平和が消えてしまっちゃいますよ
心の平和が消えてしまうだけではなくて
その二人の人間関係も
ものすごくややこしくなるんです
それで我々はさらに失敗するようになってしまっちゃうんです
だからすごい単純な論理なんですよ
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは
頭の上辺だけ ああ なるほど
そういえばその通りやと
完全な人はもういませんと
お釈迦様言ってもらわなくたっても
お釈迦様に言ってもらわなくたっても
それぐらいのこと知ってるんだというふうに気取っちゃいますけど
でも知ってるんだとか
知ったかぶりで気取ってもらっても役には立ちません
自分の人生 幸せにはしてくれません
ですから お釈迦様の言葉なんかは
私が知ってるぞと旗を上げて世の中に見せるためではなくて
本当に心の中に彫ってほしいんですよ
きちんと消えないように擦った方がいいんですよ
常に自分のこの何といいますか
よりどころ 自分のマニュアル
何かあったらすぐ参照するっていうような感じで
心のマニュアルでマニュアルになってないと役に立ちません
ですから その 4行で言ったことは大変簡単単純なことでしょう
別に難しい論理あるわけじゃないんです
昔もいなかった 過去も将来も現れません
完璧さ 完璧な人が今もいませんと
ですから 今我々にとっては今だけ大事でしょうし
ですから今我々一緒に生活している仲間がみんなまあいろいろそこそこの人々やと
いいところもあって 悪いところもあるんだと
それは理解するだけなんですよ
それだけ理解すると もう人の悪口
隠れてコソコソと言うこともなくなっちゃうし
言う必要ないんですよ
完全な人はいませんだから
何か失敗したっても それにものすごい神経質になって
ヒステリーを起こして怒鳴ったりする必要もないんですね
あるいは何回言っても聞いてくれないと
まあもう諦めてしまって
まあこの人はもう役に立ちませんと
なんで私は不幸でしょうかと
そういうふうに暗く考える必要はないんです
だから必要なのは この心の大きさと同時に謙虚であること
私が完璧ではないんだと
どうせいろいろ失敗するんだと
いくら注意したっても
気がつかないところでいろんなことを失敗したりはするんだと
ですから 大きな顔は出せませんと
で 同時に他の人も何か失敗したら
そこら辺はもう理解をすることできるようになるんですね
そういうことで この今日のテーマには結論がはっきり決まってるんですよ
ずっと研究して出す必要ないんです
不完全です 人間は 体も不完全で
心も不完全なんですよ
だから不完全な機械を持って完璧というところにチャレンジしても
結局骨が折れるだけなんですよ
さらに不幸になるだけで終わってしまっちゃいますね
だから結論ははっきりしているんです
それで時々お釈迦様の教えっていうのは
なんかどうも暗いんじゃないかなと
ちょっと批判的ではないかなと
お釈迦様はそれほどきつく批判しなかったんだけど
それにも付け加えた私の言葉の使い方はえらいもう激しいんだから
さらにもう暗く聞こえるかもしれません
今日はいくらか落ち着こうかなと
まあ一応まあ努力はしているんだけど
途中でどうなるかわかりませんよ
いきなりまた普通の調子に戻るかもしれません
で まあ座ってるんだからいくらか安心ですけど
立ってしゃべるとわからなくなっちゃうんです
で お釈迦様の教えはそういうことで
なんとか暗いんではないかと
それ暗いんじゃないんですよ
それは人々の取り方が間違っているだけであって
お釈迦様は我々には心の安らぎを教えてるんですよ
こんなヒステリーになるなよと
子どもが勉強できないんだと
だからそんなお母さんヒステリーになる必要ないんだと
落ち着きなさいよと それでも自分の子どもでしょうと
だからかわいがってあげてよと
助けてあげてよと 面倒を見てあげなさいよと
勉強する ちょっとできなくなっても
あるいは子供はいつでもどこへ行っても喧嘩するんだと
ああ 困った困ったと それに必死になって怒りよになったりしてね
病院まで行くようになるどころではないんですよ
そんなことで だからお釈迦様はすごく簡単にすぐ結果を得られる
修行の結果として幸せになるんじゃなくて
ただ理解しただけで心がそれなりに結果が得られる
このすごい特効薬なんですね
教えているのは特効薬というんで
その場合は瞬時に効く薬なんて言います
特効薬 でお釈迦様の教えは特効薬なんですよ
それからそのお釈迦の教えっていうのは
全部この狙い撃ちなんですよ
中途半端で回って どちらでも当たるところに当たってくださいということじゃなくて
ちゃんと問題に狙って答えているんですよ
ですから特効薬であって
狙い撃ちの言葉であって
聞いたら理解した途端
まあそれで幸せになるはずなんですよ
だから人間っていうのはいつでもなんか演じちゃうんですね
もうテキストなんか読んだら
ああ なるほど よくわかります
よく納得できますとかね
このお釈迦様の初期経典でも今いっぱい日本訳ありますから
まあよく納得いきますとかね
あんな気取りはどうかなと私は思いますけどね
これを納得いった よくわかったっていうことじゃなくて
本当に心の中にそれを吸っておいて刷り込まれたかないかっていうことなんですよ
で 何かあったらパッとあの言葉が思い浮かぶかないか
それがなければ そのお釈迦様のこの幸せ
お釈迦様がおっしゃっていたかった幸せを発見できないんですよ
だからお釈迦様は亡くなる時も法を島にしなさいと
よりどころにしなさいと
自己をよりどころにしなさいと
教えをよりどころにしなさいと
アッタディーパビッカウェラタ
それからダンマディーパビッカウェーウィーラタって
アッタサラナノーアンニャサラナ
他人に頼るなよと ダンマディーパビッカウェーウィーラタ
ダンマサラナ真理に頼りなさい
ノーアンニャサラナ 他のものに頼ってはいけませんと
だから自分に頼る それから真理に頼る
心の中に 自分の心の中に
この言葉を刷り込まれてもらう
そうすると それを土台にして生きられる
生きていれば それを島にして生きていればいいんです
それを導くようにして生きていればいいんです
決して悪いことにはなりません
これは100%の的中率がありまして
特効薬ですから ですから我々この人間の社会で
いつでもこの人の過ちについて
人の失敗について それから自分の過ちについて
自分の失敗について いろんなトラブルを犯しているんですよ
特にグループで行動する場合は
もう大変ややこしいんですよ
なかなかうまくいかない
ちょっとした仕切りでも間違ったらすごい怒って帰る人もいるんですよ
だから ちょっと挨拶ちょっと間違ったら
ちょっと言葉遣い間違っただけでも
まあ腹が立って帰ること
そういうふうに帰るんだけど
じゃあその方が完璧かと
また逆に聞きたいんですけどね
だからいつでも自分の不完全性をもう置いといて
他人から完璧になってほしいと希望する
それもおかしいことは自分に対してなんですよ
自分に対して完璧に対応してくれと
そんなこと世の中でありきとありきですかと
あるべきかと聞きたいぐらいのことなんですね
例えば私に挨拶間違ったら
私はもうカンカン怒ったりする
でも私がその人を他の人にものすごい丁寧に正しく挨拶しているのは見てるんですね
見ていても 私はそれ признаめたくない
人のことどうでもいいんです
彼が その人が私に対して言葉が間違ったんだと
で 怒ったりするんですね
それで自分に対してはすごくいい顔をして
世の中に悪い顔をしても
自分がその人の肩を取る
私に対して悪いことしていないんだから
私は悪い人だと思いませんよと
そういう世界もありますね
自分のものは盗まないんだけど
人のものを盗むとわかっても
私はあの人を何も盗むと思いませんよと平気で言ったりする
だから 自分に対して完璧であったらそれで十分だと
人に対してはどうでもいいんだというこの主義は間違ってあって
その代わりにすべての人間がそれぞれそこそこ生きているんだと
不完全だとということは理解しておけば
心にすごく安らぎ 落ち着きというものは出てくる
自分に対しても落ち着くんですよ
自分の自分の失敗にしたっても
まあまあ 今度頑張るんだと
そういうふうにまあ 次のことにチャレンジすればいいんです
で それで次のポイントなんですけど
じゃあ不完全だから まあどんな過ちも我々は認めるべきかという
放っておくんですか？見て見ぬふりするんですかと
人の過ち 失敗を無視するべきですかとという問題は次に来るんですね
だって不完全だからね
しょうがないんだからと
いいやと そういうふうな態度をとっていいんでしょうかと
あるいは不完全なことを間違った失敗したところで
怒鳴りつけていいんですかと
それにはお釈迦様は大体どんな問題も答える場合は
ヴィバッジャワーダという言葉を使っているんですよ
ヴィバッジャワーダ ヴィバッジャっていうのは分析
このテーラワーダ仏教のもう一つの名前があるんですよ
それはヴィバッジャワーダなんですよ
我々はすごく威張ってその言葉を使っているんです
テーラワーダ テーラワーダとあまり使わない
まあ使ってはいるんだけど
別に使わないんですよ
結局 何ワーダという何宗とかも使ってないんですから
仏教は一緒やと向こうは思っているんだから
外国なんかに行ったら
我々はどんな仏教かとなんとか言わなくちゃいけないんだから
テーラワーダというだけで
国へ帰っちゃったら何ワーダも言わないんです
で まあ一応歴史的にこの仏教は分裂しちゃったでしょうに
そこで分裂したところで
この元の人々は自分たちのことをどのように言ったかというと
ヴィバッジャワーダ このアショーカ様がもういろんな人々が
邪教の人々 違う宗教の人々も出家してごまかしやっていたんだから
みんなインタビューしたんですよ
インタビューして まあお釈迦様は何主義者ですかと聞くんだそうです
聞いたんだそうです 聞いたらヴィバッジャワーダですよと言ったお坊さんたちを
あなた方は正しいお坊さんたち
仏教のお坊さんたち 弟子たちですよと
お釈迦様はこの主義だ
この主義だと言った人々は
あなた方は仏教をわかってない
違う教えを考えているんだから出ていってくださいと
と分かれてしまったという
歴史には一応記録しているんです
ですから このお釈迦様の主義はヴィバッジャワーダという主義なんですね
だから あれ それ何なのかと
わからないです ヴィバッジャワーダパーリ語言ったってもね
ヴィバッジャっていうのは
この分析するということなんです
分けて分けて分けて 切って切って切ってみるということ
ある英語の言葉で言えば
アナリティックアナリシスムですよ
ちゃんと明確に分けてみる
まとめて大雑把で大胆で問題は見ようとしない
例えば一つの理由 例を申し上げます
最近 このまた一連の事件が起きてきたんですね
ほとんど子供たちが事故を起こし
事件を起こした 起こしたということがね
それ事件一つが出て またつなげて 2つ目に 3番目
4番目出てくると 世の中の知識人たちが
ああ 大変だ この国はどうなっているんですか？今の今ごろの若者はどうなっているんですか？今ごろの子供たちはどうなっているんでしょうかとかね
ああいうのは私から見ればいい加減な考え方で
今ごろの子供たちはどうなってもないんですよ
ただ 事件を起こしたのはただ 4つ
5つぐらいだけだから
どんな高校生も人殺したりバスジャックしたりしないでしょうに
まとめにすごい真剣 真面目に頑張っている子供たちの方が多いでしょうに
親と喧嘩したり 家庭内暴力したりする子供の数がすごく少ないでしょうに
データ取ってみれば それなのに一つの事件はものすごく大きくして
大雑把でいい加減で 喋って喋って
気が済んだら終わる それでああいう問題を起こす子供たちの役には一銭一生も役に立たない
そこでもし問題の子供が抱えているお母さんにとっても
そういう話 いくら聞いたっても
何一つも役に立ったことでなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 物事っていうのは分析した方がいいんですよ
大雑把で見て みんな同じ色で塗って塗ってもらうと
そういう生き方良くない
普通の方々は誰でも大体そういう生き方なんですね
そこら辺の外人でも誰かね
何か問題を起こしちゃったら
私にも歩けなくなっちゃうんです
同じ目で見てしまうっていうのは
そういうのは大体普通やってますけど
お釈迦様ような仏弟子たちはそうしてはいけないんだと
お兄ちゃんが殺人を起こしたんだからといって
弟も殺人扱いするのは良くないんですよ
弟は弟で ですから お釈迦様が大体分析主義
なんです ヴィパッサナー瞑想をなさっている皆様も知っているかもしれませんだけど
かなり分析させちゃうんですよ
私という大雑把な概念を
きめ細かく 小さく小さく分けて分けて分けて分けて
最小単位に分けてみるんですね
どこに私がいるんですかと
そういうアプローチなんです
ですから この今私が出した問題にしても
同じアプローチなんですよ
もう忘れたと思いますから
また繰り返しますけど
やっぱり世の中の失敗過ちを私たちは見て見ぬふりべきですか？あるいは怒鳴りついて怒鳴りつけて
それになんとかするべきかと
その時は分析的にアプローチ
した方がいいんですよ
こちらも書いてありましたから
例えば外科医がいるとする
その人の仕事は人の体を切ること
切ることと縫うことと貼ることなんですよ
まあどうせ人間失敗するんだからね
車を運転したっても たまたま失敗するでしょうに
バックしたところでぶつかったとかね
もうカーブしたところでちょっと引っかかったとこはまあ大体もうたまたまあるかもしれませんだから
じゃあ我々は外科医もまあまあそこそこ頑張ってくださいと頼むべきかと
先生 失敗したんですか？まあまあいいわ
いいわ まあ誰も失敗するんだからと
例えば手術中 もう誰かとしゃべりしゃべったところで
肺に行くべき血管はもう心臓の血管につなげたとか
そういう失敗は我々は認めるべきかというと
当たり前のことで その場合は
その人は自分の仕事は完璧にやってほしいんです
人の命を預かっているんだから
かすかな失敗も医療ミスも認めてはいけませんでしょ
だから点滴だと思って石鹸を入れたケースもあったでしょうに
人の体に石鹸か中毒剤
消毒剤ですか それで人が死んじゃったと
で 手術で患者さん入れ替えて間違ったとかね
そういう失敗はまあ認めるべきではありませんということは常識で誰でも知っています
ですから 人の命を預かったところでは １００
パーセント完璧であることはもう認めなくてはならないんですよ
それで自分の子供はもう先月の試験ではまあ９５点取ったんだけど
今月はなんで６０ですかと
それに子供をいじるべきですかと
その子供に我々は完璧
完璧ということを認めるべきですかと
それはどうってことないでしょうに
時々山手線でももうたまにあるんだけど
ほんのちょっと行き過ぎになっちゃうんですね
駅で まあまあ それでまた何のことなく電車をバックして停止位置に持ってくるんですよ
でもまあ一応運転手たちっていうのはすごく訓練を受けてますよ
ぴったし停止位置に来てきちんと止まってくれるんですよ
自動で動く電車は別としてね
大阪にもあります 東京にも１本ぐらいありますからね
完全無人電車が でもう完全無人電車は機械だから素晴らしくぴったし止まるんですよ
でも人間が操縦する場合はちょっとずれたりする
それで人を死にませんだからね
それぐらいのことでバックすればいいんですね
ですから 分析してみなくてはならないんです
世の中のことは 我々はどんな仕事で完璧性を求めるべきですか
どんな世界でまあいいやと認めるべきですか
という この分析的に世の中を見る必要があるんですよ
見たところで まあここら辺は大目に見てもよろしいと
ここら辺は厳密に見なくてはいいんだと
厳密に見なくてはならないんだと
ここら辺は要注意だと
まあ例えばまあ高速バスやらね
交通ものね 使っている運転手さんたちとかは
ものすごい要注意して仕事をしなくちゃいけない
タクシー運転手さんであろうとも
かすかな事故も起こしてはならないんですよ
個人の自分の車だったらもう勝手にもういいんですけど
ぶつかったらまああれでインシュアランスでお金もらっちゃいますからね
でも個人でも事故を起こしてはいけませんし
人に怪我しない場合はどうったことないかもしれませんだけど
でもタクシー運転手さんさんみたいなプロの場合は
わずかなキズりかすり傷でも自分の車についちゃうとちょっと心配なんですよ
高速バスやらのバスを運転する人々やらね
そういう人々はたくさんの人の命を預かっているんだから
自分の仕事はまあ完璧にしなくちゃいけない
でも少々失敗したっても
それほど死にませんだから
それは要注意するべき世界なんですね
医者の場合は要注意ではないんですよ
確実に完璧にやりなさいと
...ということを言わなくてはいけないんですね
そういうふうなことで
世の中の人間の生き方っていうのは
まあ無視したってもいいところもある
放っと放っと 放ったとしてもいい
放っておいたってもいいところもある
やっぱり一言葉言って直したところもある
注意した方がいいところもある
ものすごく厳密に注意した方がいいところもある
完璧でなければならないところもある
そのリストを持って世の中生きていれば
まあそれほど世の中に問題は起こらないと思いますね
そこでこの次のポイントなんですけど
我々はなぜ失敗するかっていうこと
そんなに頑張っているのに
そんなに真剣にやっているのに
なぜ仕事を失敗するんですかね
それも大事なポイントなんですよ
具体的な例で言えば 例えば試験には一生懸命真面目に勉強はしたんだけど
試験は失敗してしまったとかね
仕事の場合でも一生懸命やったんだけど
結局は失敗してしまったと
何なのかと そんな一生懸命やっているのに
その場合もやっぱり少々分析して考えないと
いくつかの原因は考えられます
その中で一番大きな原因は
この過剰自信なんですよ
自分がプロだと もう分かったもんだと
慣れたもんだと どうってことないんだと
任せておけと という感じでいろんな仕事に手を出す
その過剰自信が危険の第１
あの原子放射の事件が起きたのは
何のことなく過剰自信
あのいくつか原子炉で事故を起こしたでしょうに
すべて過剰自信 過剰自信で手抜く
大丈夫や なんであんな過剰自信するんですかね
この不完全であるということは忘れているんですよ
原子炉はもう完璧に作ったんだからと思っても
不完全であると 一つの原子炉で何かあの
あのハードボード なんとか水を使ってクーリングしますね
冷却 そこで冷却といったってものすごい恐ろしく熱いんだけど
それはまあなんとかパイプで水を流れていますけど
そういうのはまあものすごい専門的なところで
厳密にレントゲンで見ながら見ながら作っているものなんです
それでもどこかでほんのちょっとの血管が...変えたりして
どうしても見つかりっこはないぐらいの
ほんのちょっとのとこなんですよ
でも あのものすごい熱い
すごい圧力で水が流れていると
どんどん金属疲労でそこら辺で割れ目が入っちゃったりする
だから あの完璧だ 大丈夫だということは危険なんですよ
どれほど技術能力でもうそういうものを作っても
やっぱり何かあるかもしれませんという二重
三重 四重ぐらいのもう安全ということを考えなくてはいけませんね
これで間違ったらこれで直るぞと
これで間違ったらこれで直るぞという
この過剰自信 一番問題なんですよ
運転する人で 私にとっては目を閉じてでも運転できるぞとか思ったら
すぐ死んじゃいますからね
この運転手さんの中でも
私は自分の国でよく聞いたんだけど
あの免許なしにもう何人かに聞いたんだけども
何年も運転しているんですよ
だから車小さい時からもうね
まあもういじったりして
もうせいぜい車のもう座れるぐらい背が高くなっちゃったら
もうあっちこっちまあ運転してみたりする
どんどん自信がついちゃって
道路でも運転したりして
で 大体事故を起こさないと警察は調べるということはしませんだから
もうただ道路で車行くたびに調べる必要ないでしょうし
全然警察に見つかったことも何もなくて
それで一年 二年経っちゃうと一年
二年も経ちますよ 無免許で運転したりして
やっぱり大人が心配していくらなんでももうあんたは車を運転もできるんだから免許を取りなさいと言ったら
まあ行って免許を取る
もう何のことなく一回で免許証合格してもらっちゃう
ある人いたんですよ 免許を取って週間経ったところで捕まったんだと
私は年も運転していたのに
無免許で捕まったことはなかったんだと
だから免許取りたてで何か問題起こす
捕まっちゃったら それも免許にもちょっと良くないでしょうに
どういうことかというと
免許を取れたんだ あの紙枚もらっちゃったんだから
もう過剰自信 もう怖いものはないんだと
だから たとえ免許証をもらっても
車を運転するたびに要注意するということは一生なんですよ
年間車を運転したんだから
もう心配する必要ないんですかね
あるんですよ それでも
ですから 人間にこの過剰自信というものがついちゃって
それは良くない 危険 お釈迦様その場合もこういう芸がありまして
自分が知ってるんだと思ったらアホになるんだと
自分がそれほどもう知ってるわけじゃないと思ったら
もう毎日毎日その人の智慧が増えていくんだとという意味の言葉があるんですよ
で 直訳するとちょっと意味が変わりますけど
よーばーよばろ マニャティバルヤン
パンディトわーぴてなそう
もし愚か者が自分が愚か者であることを知っているならば
それだけで彼がパンディト賢者ですよと
ただそれだけのことで
私は愚か者だと認めてんだったら
もうじりじりと賢者になるんだと
バーローピパンディタマニ
頭が悪いのに 愚か者であるのに
パンディトマニ 私はもう賢者だよと
物事を知っているんだと思ったら
セウェーバーローと言って打っちゃって
その人はずっと愚か者だと
無知な人になるんだという言葉なんですね
だからそちらに言っているのは
この過剰自信ということなんですね
だから まあそこそこは知ってるんだと
まあそこそこはできるんだということを自分の頭の中で置いておくと
過剰自信がなくなっちゃう
で 毎日毎日頭が進んでいくんです
訓練の場合は 毎日毎日自分の腕が磨いていくんですよ
だから このよく世の中で見えるものが
この技術は世界一だとか
何でも世界一論を持ってくるんですね
だから何でしょうかね
技術は世界一だと言ったら
もしかすると技術は世界一かもしれません
でもそれは技術は完璧だという意味じゃありませんよ
よく私の耳に入りますからね
やっぱりもう我々の技術はもう世界一だとかね
まあ日本は神の国だと言ったような感じで
勝手に何言ったっても私は気にしませんだけど
もう大したことはないんですけど
でもそこで危険なところがあるんですよ
論理性 世界の技術と比べてみたら
自分の技術は世界一かもしれません
それで別に悪いわけじゃないんですよ
だから言って完璧ではありません
そこでちょっとしたミスを犯しちゃうんですよ
まあ本当に確かにたくさん品物ありますよ
日本でしか作れないものっていうのは
技術的なもの 科学的なものもいっぱいありますよ
まあ日本でしか作れない
他のとこで作るんだけど
どうもうまくいかないとかね
だからその点でやっぱり世界一だというのは間違ってはないんです
でも人間はそれはそこまで間違ってないんだけど
世界一ということは完璧という意味ではないんだと
それでもどこかでどうぞ足を伸ばしてください
あの 足が痛い方々はどうぞ気楽に座ってください
あの世界一の技術であろうとも
いろいろ直さなくちゃいけないところ
さらに進歩させなくちゃいけないところいっぱいあるんだと
安全だと 完璧だと言ってほっとすることは絶対できませんということは理解してもらわないと
だから この失敗を起こす原因の一番大きい原因はそれなんです
過剰自信 謙虚じゃないんですよ
頭が 知ってるんだと たとえもう外科の教授であろうとも
もうもう 25歳からもうもう 50歳になるまでずっと手術してきたんだと思っても
もうプロ中プロで それでも一個一個の手術にすごい真剣でやってもらわないと
困るんですよ 日本にそういうケース一つ起きたでしょ
エイズのエイズ感染問題で
血液なんとか薬をね 加熱処理しないで使ってもいいんだと
あの方が決していい加減な教授ではなかったんですよ
大変な一流のものすごい素晴らしい教授でしたけど
逆にアホでしたから 正しい科学者であるならば
1万の 일부でも問題が起こるんだったら気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
加熱処理しなかった薬を入れただけでいて
病気でかかったことはないんだと思っても
一人 でもなったならば危険なんですよ
なぜかというと その患者にその薬になったらどうするんですかね
それでたくさんの人を大変不幸なことにしてしまっちゃったんです
その時も その人がデータを持っていたんですよ
研究データ 持っていたんだけど
どこかで過剰自信で この割合で計算してね
まあまあ いくつかのケースが出ていたんだけど
みんななったわけじゃないんだと
そんないい加減さで人が死んじゃいますからね
だからプロ中のプロになってくると
なんかすごく高慢になってしまって
過剰自信になるんですよ
そこはどんなプロでもすごく気をつけなくちゃいけないことなんですよ
なぜかというと プロ中プロになると
自分には目上の人がなくなっちゃうんですよ
みんな弟子たちだから
生徒たちだから それでもみんな先生どうですか？この場合はどうですか
この場合はどうですか？ってみんな自分から聞くんだから
自分の言ったことは神の言葉のように生徒たちが聞いているんだから
そうするとついついなってしまっちゃう
ですから たとえある分野で世界一のプロになっても
世界一プロっていうのは
その人の上 誰もいないということなんですよ
そこで その人にとってはみんな小さく見えるんです
他に小さく見えるんだからといって
自分が完璧というわけじゃないんですね
それでも本当に自分の心の謙虚ということは守ってもらわないと失敗は起こるんですよ
そうでないと失敗は起こりません
プロの世界では ですから
一番大事な問題というのは過剰自信であること
それもプロにもよく起こる現象で
プロでない人にもたまたま起きたりして
そこで失敗する で まあ自信ついちゃったらね
過剰自信ついちゃったらね
まあ気をつけた方がいい
ほとんどの場合は失敗する
試験の場合でも ああ これは私にできるぞと思ったら失敗する
だからこの過剰自信を置いておく
少々やばいと思った方がいいんですよ
ちゃんとチャレンジしないと
ちゃんとチャレンジしないといけないんだと
全身でもうアプローチしないと
うまくいかないということを理解してほしいんですね
次に失敗する原因というのはそれほど大したことではないんだけど
まあわかりやすいことで
あまり気が入らない 中途半端でね
まあ嫌で嫌でやると もうやってあげますとかね
やっぱりやらなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そういう あんまりこの真剣さがなくなっちゃうと失敗しちゃう
時々 人っていうのは仕事を軽く見るという性格があるんですよ
それぐらいのことかと
それは大体単純な仕事でよく出てくることなんですよ
例えばずっと 年間も主婦をなさった方がいるとする
だから20年間も料理なんか作って作ってきたんだから
もう慣れたもんですよ
そうすると まあ軽く見ちゃう
もう料理のプロだから
事故 事故 事故起きたりします
天ぷら油に火がついたりとかね
起きたりします 時々何回も家が火事になったりとかね
あったでしょ ああいうのは
毎日やっていたことだから
20年間もやってきたんだからね
事故を起こしたことないんですよ
そうすると もう軽いと思っちゃうんですね
その軽いと思うところが危険なんですよ
たとえ炊飯器でご飯を炊く時でも
毎日炊いてもちゃんと水の量がチェックした方がいいんです
何年経っても 何十年かもご飯炊いても
毎回毎回水の量をチェックした方がいいんです
そうでないとどこかでちょっと失敗する可能性ありますね
だから このまあ それほど難しい仕事ではありませんとというふうな気持ちもよくないんですよ
私が言いたいのは たとえこれは拭いてくださいと雑巾で言ったら
まあそんなこともう簡単だ
なんでつまらないことを頼むんですかと
...気持ちでやっちゃうとうまくできないんですよ
その ただ雑巾をかける仕事であろうとも
真剣でそれなりに それは大体この日本の禅宗ではそういう話はよくありますよ
仕事はまあどんな単純な仕事でも
これはもう単純じゃないんだ
そういう言葉ではないんだけど
こちらプロの方々がいますけど
なんて言いますか つまらない仕事とすごい面白い仕事
そんなことはありはないんだと
たとえ掃除にしたっても
ほうきをかけることにしたっても
もうたたきでほこりをたたくことにしたっても
一つ一つ大事な仕事なんですよ
その仕事にはやり方があるんですよ
目的があるんですよ そこで 100点満点でやらなくちゃいけないんです
だから それも人間に必要なこと
ついつい掃除機かけると
まあまあまあ なんとかさっさとかけて回ったりする
あの仕事を軽く見るということはよくないんですね
何一つも軽く見てはいけません
トイレに行くことにしたっても
で 軽く見るんだから トイレに行って帰ると電気がついたまんまでしょうに
家を出るたびにもう慣れたもんやと思ってはいけません
ちゃんと電気消したか
ガス消したか 鍵をかけたかとかね
それ中途半端なとこ私もありますけど
今はいつでも鍵は鍵を忘れることはないはめになってますけどね
で 前は大体もう別にということにもあったんですけどね
ですから まあそういういい加減なところはどんな人間にもありますよ
私にももう言えないぐらいいっぱいありますけど
いい加減なところは まあでもやっぱり一つ一つ仕事を軽く見ないで真剣にやるということは大変大事なんですね
それ軽く見て私も結構損したことはありますよ
軽く ああ こんな軽い軽いと思ったところで失敗しまして
その失敗を直すためにお金まで結構かかったりとかね
悔しいんですよ なんでこれとこれ調べなかったんですかと
知ってるつもりでやったんだからとかね
自分のことを悔しがったりするんだけど
やっぱり単純な仕事であろうが
雑巾かけることであろうか
ホコリをたたきでたたくことであろうか
単純やと思ったら何か問題が起こるんです
ですから 過剰自信は良くないことと
まあどんなことでも仕事でも軽く見ないことと
軽く見ないことですごくいいポイントもありますよ
このつまらないと そんな単純やと
なんで私がこれまでこれもやらなくちゃあかんかと
そんな気持ちで仕事をすると
まず仕事は中途半端で失敗だらけでもあるし
やった人も気持ちが悪いんですよ
例えば ある人のあなた
トイレの掃除をお願いしますと言ったら
なんで私はトイレ掃除に任されるんですか？とかね
と思っちゃうと そのトイレ掃除もろくにやれませんし
本人はやったんだけど
すごい気持ちが悪い そういうことはもう不幸なんですね
だから道路であんたビラを配ってくださいと頼まれたら
まあそれは大事な仕事としてすごい気持ちよくやればいいんです
例えば どこかの店にバイトに行ったところで
もうレジは任せてくれない
その代わりにこのもう床の掃除しなさいと言ったら
その道具を持って一生懸命気持ちよくそれをやればいいんですよ
そうするとぴったしきれいになりましたという気持ちもあるし
仕事を頼んだ人にとっても
よく真面目にやってくれるんだと
という気持ちも出てきて
明るく終わっちゃうんですよ
ですから 仕事にはもう上と下はないことね
それは日本では常識ですけどね
常識は常識ですけど やっぱりやるときはそうじゃないんですね
どうも課長にならなきゃ気が済まない人もいるんだからね
部長にならなきゃ気が済まない
課長にならなきゃ気が済まない
総理大臣にならなくちゃ気が済まないという人がいるんだから
なったところで失敗だらけなんでしょうに
だから総理大臣にならなくてもいいんですよ
課長 部長にならなくてもいいんですよ
自分に任された仕事はきれいに真剣にやればいいんですね
その 2番目の原因はそれなんですね
仕事は面白くないとかね
私にはすごいたくさんのことができるのに
なんでそんなことを頼むんですかという
この軽く見ることと過剰自信とできるんだという過剰自信と
なんでそんなつまらないことを頼むんですかという
それも高慢なんですけど
まあ間でいくつかの原因がありますけど
大体まあ集中しないでね
ながら職でテレビを見ながら天ぷらを揚げるとかね
で まあそういう場合もいろいろトラブル起きたりする
それから言われるんだから
母親に言われるんだから
勉強すると勉強はうまくいくがないんですね
命令されたんだからやると
うまくいかない  そういういくつかの原因がありますね
失敗する原因は えーと
休憩何時ですか？でもえっ？一応前回でこのなぜ失敗するかという原因
まあ本当は2つしか言ってないんだけども
間でもいろいろたくさんありますけど
それは全部言う必要はないと思います
大体は中途半端で 何か他のことを何かやりながら
あるいはあまり興味がなくて
あるいは言われるんだからとか
そういう気持ちでいろんなことをやると
もうほとんどの場合は失敗する
まあそこら辺はたくさんありますけど
あまりご自分でもお分かりになるだろうと思います
で 次にまあどうせ休憩なぜ取るかというと
2番目になってくると結構規則が
で 完璧主義って一体何なのかと
ということなんです で
あの完璧であることを
あるいは完璧になりたいという気持ち自体がお釈迦様から言えば邪見なんですよ
正しい考え方じゃないんです
正見ではありません それにチャレンジすると
その人々は邪見に基づいてチャレンジするんだから
決して幸福になるわけじゃありませんと
この邪見という言葉 ミッチャーディッティ
間違っている考え方っていうのは
仏教ではまあそれは大変な厳しいこととして言ってるんですよ
お釈迦様もこの人を脅したりとかね
そういうことはあまりしませんだけど
人の失敗なんかはそれほど気にしなかったし
人が罪を犯しても まああんまりそんなに真剣に気にするということはないんですよ
でも 何も罪を犯さなくても
考え方がおかしいんだったら
すごく重罪を犯したような人の感じでしゃべったりするんですね
それで罪もいろいろリストがあるんだけど
軽い罪から重い罪まで一番重い罪になっているのは邪見なんですよ
それも一般的には世の中で認めないかもしれません
仏教では人殺しよりも邪見が重い罪なんですよ
本当にそんなそうですか？と思うかもしれません
でもそうなんです どういうことかというと
人間が自分の考え方によって生き方を構成するんですよ
調整するんですよ 我々はどんな生き方をしているんですか？どんな行動をしているんですかと
すべて本人が心で決まっている
自分なりの自分だけのポリシーに基づいているんですよ
それは自分自身の哲学なんですよ
どんな人間も まあ私の哲学というものは持っているんですよ
子供は子供の哲学を持っていて
母親は母親の哲学を持っているんです
それで母親の言う通りにやるわけじゃないんですよ
先生の言う通りにやるわけじゃないんですよ
みんな自分が持っている哲学に基づいて
これ哲学と言うんでしょうか
わかりませんだけど まあポリシーですけどね
自分が自分の心で決め
決めているポリシーによって生活しているんですよ
たとえ私がこんなことを喋ったっても
みんな同じくならないんでしょうに
決して変わらない人もいるんだけど
なかなか同じくはならないんですよ
それはなぜかというと
私の話は ご自分の哲学という自分の人生論
人生観という器に入れて使っているんだから
そういうことで 個人差っていうのは出てくる
平等になるということはないんです
みんな同じくなるということ
そういうことだから 個人が持っている哲学
ポリシー 理論 ものの見方っていうのは大変大事なことなんです
そこはすべての決まり手なんですよ
すべてのものの そういうことだから
人が人を殺したかないかということよりも
大事なのは その人が持っている自分なりの理念なんですよ
そこは間違っているとどうなるんでしょうかね
どうしようもないんですよ
例えば 人がたまたま腹が立って人を殺したりする
それでも自分の理念というのは
自分が立派な人間では生活したいんだという理念だったら
その人を直せるんですよ
本当は立派な人間で生きていきたいんだと
たまたまいろいろ事件も条件があって人を殺してしまったということだから
その人には立ち直ることは何のことなくできる
もし自分の理念が間違っているんだったら
どうにもならないんですよ
ですから 罪の中で一番重い罪が何なのかと
仏教から聞くと理念なんです
個人が持っている理念
個人の哲学 個人が持っているポリシー
そこは邪険になってほしくないんですよ
完璧にならないとならないんだからね
それは完璧にはならないんだけど
邪見にしては欲しくないんですね
だからこの完璧主義っていうのは邪見ですということはどういうことかとこれから説明します
お釈迦様がすべてのものは無常であると
すべて変化するんだと
それから無常と同時にドッカという言葉を教えたんですね
ドッカの意味は 感覚的には苦しいという意味なんですけど
哲学的には無常であることと不完全であることなんですよ
すべてのものは 心と物事
一切のものが不完全なんです
どう見ても見えるものはすべて不完全でしょうに
不完全だから物事変化するんですよ
だから花が咲いたら 大体この花は完全だよと思っても
花にとっては満開になった
花にとっては自分が完璧な状態になったわけじゃないんですよ
あれは他の状態のための準備段階だけなんですよ
ですから 花が次の状態になるんですよ
その状態になっても それは完全な状態ではありません
その状態が次の段階に行かなく状態に変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから止まることは物事にないんです
完成になったらそれで終わりなんです
それ以上成長する必要はなくなっちゃうんですね
だから種は不完全だから
種は芽が出るためのものだからね
だから芽が出る それは不完全だからちょっと伸びちゃう
それが不完全だから葉っぱが出てくるとか
その状態は不完全だからどんどんどんどんどんどん変わっていく
だから一つの状態でも完全ではありません
完全だったらそこでピタッと止まるはずなんです
ですから 不完全イコール無常なんです
完璧という概念が完璧になりたい
完璧主義の私は完璧やとか思う人々が無常に逆らって無常でありませんと
という科学的な真理に逆らって逆さまのことを考えているんですよ
だから邪見なんです その邪見に戻して生活すると
もう出てくるのは必ずしもトラブル
苦しみ 悩み 問題なんです
ですから 完全主義というのはもう正真正銘の邪見なんです
完璧主義というのは ありえないんです
それはもう面白くないと言ってもしょうがないんですよ
あなたは何言ったって私は完全だとと思ったってもしょうがないことなんですね
だから邪見的に人の機嫌を取ってしゃべる場合は何でもしゃべれますよ
あなた方は神の子供ですよとかね
何でももうかっこいい言葉を言えるんですけど
そういうふうに言う人々もいますね
人間は神様が作ったんだから
もう神の子供ですよと
みんな気持ちいいんですよ
神の心で気持ちいいんだけど
だらしないのはそのままでしょうに
そんなこと言ってくれたっても
どこで我々の生き方に役に立つんですかね
だから美しい言葉かもしれませんよ
人々のことをすごく褒めて言ってくれる言葉なんですけど
絶対たる神様の直々の言葉だと
まあ素晴らしい言葉ですけど
役には立ちません ちょっとイメージしてみてください
私は神様の息子ですよと
娘ですよと それでどうなりますかね
それで危険を起こす可能性はいくらでもありますけど
うまくいく可能性はないんですよ
だから私はより良い人間にならなくちゃいけないという理論になりません
だから父親は神様だからね
何が失敗したってもね
全部向こうはなんとかしてくれるんだということで
緊張さがなくなっちゃうんですよ
生きることの緊張さというんですかね
緊張というものはなくなっちゃうんですよ
ですから 注意深く生きていなくちゃいけないということが消えちゃうんです
同じく仏教の世界でみんなまあ仏様の息子だよと言ったっても同じことなんですよ
みんな本来悟ってるんだとか何とか言ったってもね
本学だと言ったっても役に立ちません
でも言葉自体は大変 この人間のことをすごく尊く考えて言ったことかもしれません
もしかすると そんなことを最初に言った人々が
自分が世の中を見るとどんな目で見ているんですかと
他人を見ると自分のアプローチだよと言った方がものすごいかっこいいのに
だからブッダの教えでもいいし
誰の教えでもいいんだけど
こういう仏教を信じている人々が
他人様を見る時はみんな仏様だとという気持ちで見た方がいいんじゃないか
そういうふうに見たら
自分の生き方が必ずも謙虚的になって
すごく気をつけて生きることになります
そこで言葉が間違っちゃうんですね
間違って本来悟っているんだよと言って開き直る
開き直って修行をやめる
努力することをやめちゃう
それから失敗する 堕落するということにはなりますね
ですから お釈迦様の教えになってくると
あんまり大胆なことを人間は褒めてないし
まあ不完全だと でお釈迦様はよく使っている言葉って愚か者という言葉だからね
神の子という言葉使ってないんです
私の子という言葉は全然使いません
愚か者という言葉を使っているんです
パーリ語だったらバーラという言葉
その点でも仏教の教えの態度っていうのは
まあちょっときつければきついんですけどね
だからまあ 先生が生徒たちを叱るような感じなんですね
でも甘い もう何でもいいやいやで無視する先生よりは
まあちょっとまあ 何て言いますか
スズメバチみたいに まあちょっと間違ったら刺すというぐらいの先生だったら
やっぱりもう無邪気な生徒たちがね
しっかりするんでしょうし
まあそういうことだから
すべてのものは不完全である
だから変化していく その中に完全性っていうのは認めることはできません
ありえない それなのに
人間の心の中で完全主義という気持ちがみんなの心の中には入り込んでいる
それは邪見であると それは見方が狭いんだからなるんですよ
で 次のポイントなんですけど
なんで心の中にそういう問題が起こるかと
で こういう例で考えましょう
あるお母さんに生まれた子が障害があるとする
そのお母さんが世の中の他の子供を見たことがないならば
子供は見たことがない
見たのは唯一の自分の子供だけ
障害があってもわかりますかね
自分の子供には生まれつき何か欠点があるんだと
わかりますかね それでなぜ自分の子供が何か欠点を持って生まれたんだとわかるかというと
他の人の子供と比べるんだからでしょ
自分の子供の成績が悪いんだとどうやってわかるんですかね
何かと比べるんだからわかるんであって
そうでないか問題がないんですよ
自分の家に咲いた花が
それはそれできれいなんですけど
きれいな花だなと思って
隣の家の庭の花も見ると
見ちゃうとそちらの方がもっと綺麗で
もっと立派という風に見えちゃうと
自分のものは小さく見えちゃうんですね
そういうこと あるいは自分の庭の花を見たら
まあ花も咲いていることで
まあどうったことないやと思っている人がいるとします
これ反対側 そう思っていたところで
まあそっち散歩にすると
人の庭も見る そちらも花が咲いてるんだけど
まあそれほど庭も大きくはないし
花の手入れしてないし
肥料もあげてないし 水もかけてないし
だから花も小さくて変化して
もうあまりかっこよくない
それで あっ 私の庭の花は一番やと
という気持ちになるんですよ
それでかっこつけちゃうんです
ここ この住宅街で 私の庭の花は一番綺麗やと
で 高慢になる 最初はそうではなかったんですよ
まあ花も咲いて当たり前やと
ちゃんと面倒見たんだからと
今の時期になると花が咲くのも当たり前で
っていうぐらいで落ち着いていたのに
隣と比べたところで余計なことになる
例えば逆に ただ自分の子供は小さい時からいつでも点数は 100点満点取ってくるんですね
で まあ毎日のことだから別にどうったことはない
それでも子供叱ったりとかいろいろしたり
もういい加減せんかとか何とか言ったりはする
それでいろいろ他のお母さんたちと付き合うことになったりして
他の人々の情報やらいろいろ調べたところで
みんなもう 100点取った人は一人もいないと
自分の子供だけだとわかったところから大変なんですね
うちの子はまあこういう子やと
それでまた自慢したり
高慢になったりしたりする
だからそれはどこから出てくる問題ですか
完全の問題はこの比べるんだから出てくる問題なんですよ
比較する この比較することは仏教での用語でマーナと言うんですね
あるいは日本語でこの慢
高慢という言葉で使っている慢なんですね
比べてみると 自分と他人を
自分と他人を比べてみれば
いくらでも悲観的になるとこはいくらでもありますよ
悔しくなることはいくらでもありますよ
ですから この比較することはすごい煩悩なんですよ
比較することは不可能なんです
この花と他の花っていうのはどうやって比較するんですかね
木が違うんだから枝も違いますから
当たる光も違いますから
失礼なんですよ お姉ちゃんと弟を比べると
これ失礼なんですよ 自分の子供同士でも比べないでしょうに
一人が年上で一人が年下だから
だからとんでもないことをやっているんですよ
我々は みんなすごい苦労するでしょ
痩せるために比べては痩せたくなる
どんどん針のように痩せても気がつかないかもしれませんよ
どんどん人間痩せてしまっちゃって
まあ竹ぐらいに痩せちゃったところで
それでも他のものに比べてもっと痩せたいと思うかもしれません
それぐらい行き過ぎに
まあまあ まだなってないんだけど
もう行き過ぎになるってことはありますよ
このブランド思考やらね
アクセサリーの思考やらおしゃれの思考やらね
全部比べる世界でしょ
言って言ってどこまで行くかと
言って苦しみばっかり作っちゃうんですよ
比べるんだから この限定品という思考まで出ているんですよ
まあくだらんカバンですけど
これは限定品で 1万個しか作ってないんだと
それで番号もちゃんと付いているんだと
で いくらでもお金払って買う
何のためでしょうかとかね
ただ心の変な病気でしょうに
だから比べるということは一番大きな問題で
比べることは煩悩であって
愚か者しか物事を比べないんですよ
これ科学的じゃないんです
比べるということ だから一つ一つのものが別なものなんですよ
たとえ似ていても 例えば私が写真撮って
写真 ３枚 コピー 3枚もらったとする
同じものですかね  3枚も別々なものなんです
比べることはできないんです
別な紙でしょうし 別な薬品でしょうし
ですから 普通の世間で我々はいろんなものに尺度を持ってね
まあ比べたり測ったりいろいろしますけど
それは人生にはダメなんです 1
日中何グラムぐらいお塩を使いますかと
何グラムぐらい砂糖しますかと使いますかとかね
それは測ったってもいいんだけど
人生においては比べることは無知な行為なんです
知恵の行動じゃないんですね
だからできれば頭から物事を比べることを捨ててしまえば
もう比較する相手がないんだから
もう完成 完璧か不完全か
そんなことを気にしなくなっちゃうんです
そのそのものがそのもので放っておくんですよ
上の子がすごい体力があって
体がすごいでっかいと
下の子はいつでももうやせっぽちで弱いんだと
放っておけばいいんですよ
そんなことは 筋肉がつかない
あまり食べない 下の子もそのままでいいし
その子はすごい筋肉ついてる
もう体ができている子供と同じくやろうとしちゃうと
みんなに不幸 やられる側にも
やる側にも だから一つ何一つも比べることは不可能であって
比べたがる気持ちが煩悩であると
自分の心が汚れているんだからそうなっているんだということをもし理解できれば
完璧主義というのはもう飛んじゃいますよ
だから比較すること 比べることをなくなったならば
消える現象だから それは独立して世の中にあることじゃないんですよ
完璧主義っていうことは
まあただそれだけのことはすごい簡単単純なことなんです
で まだ逆な見方もありますよ
まだ逆な見方あります
全部完全ではないかと
例えば花が咲いた でも花びらが
一つ二つ伸びてないんだと
小さいんだと 花の種類によってもありますが
例えばバラの話であっても
あるところで花びらが短かったら
もうあまりいい花じゃないんですよ
形として丸く見えないんですね
あ この花が不完全だと言えるのは
他のバラの花と比べる時ですよ
ちゃんと花びらが同じ大きさで伸びてるんだったら
これは完璧な花で この花が完璧じゃないんだと
見ちゃう 比べると逆な見方で見れば
そのこの花がそれしかできないんですよ
その花が 花びらが短い花が
それは自分にできる精いっぱいのことをしているんですよ
わざと短くしたわけじゃないんです
種 2つ植えたところで
1本はすごく太くて芽が出てきて
1本はすごく細くてと
それはその 2つの種が自分にできる動力を能力をいっぱい発揮しているんですよ
何も欠けてるわけじゃないんです
完璧なんです 生まれてきた子供の目が見えないとしたっても
それは不完全な状態じゃないんですよ
それはその DNA がもう組み立てたところで
一番百満点 百点満点で出した結果ですよ
それ以上出せません それで完全ですよ
例えば 1500 CC の軽自動車を運転して
その車はまあせいぜい 65 キロしかスピードを出さないと言っても
その車が自分の能力をフルに使っているんですよ
何か欠けてるわけじゃないんです
それはなんで3500 リッターの車に比べるんですかね
その比べ方は間違ってるんですよ 3500
リッターの車がもうスピードはもう 100 以上出すっていうのはそちらの能力なんですよ
ですから 世の中はこのままでいいんですよ
見方によります 比べるか比べないかと
だから比べないで見ると
まあそれはそれでいいんですよ
英語上手な日本の方がいるとする
いくら勉強したっても
なかなか心に留まらない
日本のもう一人の人もいる
いいじゃない 放っておけば
そのその人の能力はそれぐらいだから
だからもう今も電気 4つぐらいついてますけど
これは太陽の光のようにもう何千万ワットぐらいのエネルギーを出してほしいと思ったら
それとんでもない話でしょ
これは日本武道館の明かりと比べる必要はありますかね
日本武道館だったらもっと明るいでしょうとかね
だからそこはものすごい非科学的なんですよ
どんなものも完全ですよ
見方を変えてみれば で
例えばこの台はちょっと傾いているとする
そこで私はビー玉一つ落としちゃったら
ビー玉が転がって転がっていくでしょ
で 転がってて どこかで止まるんですよ
だからそこでいいということなんです
だから物事は因果法則によって生まれるんだというお釈迦様の話がありますね
それも仏説ですけど 因果法則から考えちゃうと
原因条件そろったら結果が出る
そちらには完全だ 不完全だということはあり得ない話なんです
私は両手叩いたら音が出るでしょうに
それは音は不完全やと言えますかね
両手はどのように叩いたかと
叩いたかと 手のどこら辺
どこら辺触れたかと 空気の温度はどれぐらいですかと
部屋のなんとか何とか条件はどれぐらいですかとか
それによって音の響きやら強さやらもう決まってるんですよ
それ以上もそれ以下も出せません
こうやって音をするでしょうに
それは完全な音で こうやってしたらそれは完全な音なんです
前の音と次の音を比べちゃうと変なんですけど
だから ある子供はものすごくもうもうヒステリーになってキャーキャーキャーと泣いていると
それは変な子供ではなくて
その子供が置かれている条件によって
そういう結果しか出せないだけなんですよ
笑えないんです その時は
そういう条件に置かれているんだから
この子はいつまでも泣いて
なんで他の子供と同じく笑ってくれないかと言ったっても
それはこちらの考え方が間違っているんであって
比べているんだから それはそれで完全なんです
完全というのは ですから
まあ完全主義と言うならば
言いたければ別に言ったってもいいんですよ
でも知識に知恵に基づいて言いたいんです
言ってほしいんです 文句言ってはいけません
完全だと思うならば すべてことごとく完全なんです
なんで文句を言うんですかと
不完全だと言いたければ
すべてことごとく不完全なんです
文句言う必要ないんです
だから犬を見たっても
同じ種類の犬にしたっても
毛の長さはそれぞれまちまちでしょうに
そのその体では作られるぐらいのギリギリのところまで毛を伸びていますよ
色も同じことでしょうに
それぞれの体で出せるぐらいの色を出しているんです
なんで白い犬が黒い犬になってほしいと思いますかね
なんで毛が短い犬が毛が伸びてほしいと思いますかね
そこは人間の比べる世界だから出てくることなんです
比べる世界はまた高慢であって
慢であって無知だから出てくるんですね
まあそういうことだから
完全主義も不完全主義もね
まあどうして当てにならない
まあ人間のうわごとにしか何もないんじゃないかなと思いますけどね
ですから そういうことだから
花は力いっぱい咲いてますよ
たとえ花びらがつ3つ欠けていても
その花自体が力いっぱい
100パーセントで頑張っているんです
それはもう花だからそうなんですよ
石が一つ投げちゃったら
その石が転がって転がって
自分が安定できるところで止まるんです
自然の世界では で 人間にも同じことを考えてみれば
人間が自分の意思で努力するところが自分の百パーセントを出しちゃえばいいんです
自分の努力で それが比べる必要ないんです
比べると不完全になるんであって
比べないと不完全でも何でもなく
これは自分の百パーセントの力の結果ですよと
それで腹が立ったり困ったりする必要なくなっちゃうんです
だから この完璧主義の場合は
この人間に対して喋る場合は
人間が自分で考えて行動しているんですよ
その時は中途半端で手抜きで
ながら職で もう何かもうやりながらやったりとか
そういうことではなくて
集中して それにはもう自分の百パーセント出す能力
そうすると百パーセントの結果が出る
その結果は他の人のものと比べる必要はないんです
幼稚園の子供が描く文章であろうが絵であろうが
すごい綺麗でしょ？かっこいいんです
大人になってくるとどうったことはないんです
なぜかというと 子供なんか字一つ書いても
もう鉛筆はギューッと握って
もう力いっぱい出して書いてるんですよ
もう紙も一応折れたりもする場合もありますけど
で なんとかすごく可愛いんですよ
あれで力いっぱいでやっているんだから
やっと自分の名前書いただけかもしれませんよ
でも ちっちゃな子供は自分でもう鉛筆をにじって名前書いたら
あれはすっごいいい作品なんですよ
子供の心も見えるし 年もわかるし
可愛いということも感じてくるし
それは書道のプロの文字となんで比べるんですかね
それ大人になってくると
我々はよく失敗するんですね
人と比べて 人と比べているだけで
自分の力いっぱいというものは出さなくなっちゃうんですね
だから力いっぱい出せないのは間違いなんですよ
力いっぱい出すと それはそれでもう完璧です
他のことはありえないんです
あの まあ大体はこの完璧主義っていうのはそれほど難しいテーマではありません
えっとまあ難しく喋るするならば
いくらでも喋れますけど
まあそれは因果法則ということも考えなくちゃいけないし
因縁の法則で物事は条件によって生まれてくるんだということに
だから条件によって生まれてくるんだから
その結果しかは出せません
で 因果法則だから マッチをね
ボックスの薬ついているところに
もう適当な力で刺したら火が出る
それはダイナマイトにはなりません
爆発とはしません マッチは自分に持っている力いっぱい出す
そこは完全か不完全かということになり立たないんですよ
もしマッチ棒についている薬の中にいろいろ不純物なんか入っていたならば
火がなんか変な形で出る
それでそのマッチがダメということじゃなくて
比べるダメなんですけど
そのマッチも自分に持っていたエネルギーは力いっぱい出してるんですよ
そこでもう 1本のマッチをつけてもつけても火がつかなかったと
それはそのマッチが持っていた力なんです
薬は落ちちゃったんだけど
湿気が裂いて裂いてしまっちゃって
で 火がつかなかったら
それはそちらの力いっぱいなんです
だから 1500CC の車と 300CC の車は比較しません
頭のいい人だったら そういうことで
この因果法則っていうものは世の中であって
それによっていろんなことは出てくる
だから人間には意志という自分の気持ちで考えるということがあるんだから
いろんな余計なことを考えたり
高慢をしたり ストレス溜まったりとかね
そういうことをしないで
気持ちよく 明るく 毎日の仕事に
たとえつまらない仕事とか偉い仕事とか
そんな区別もなし  1 秒 1 秒何かやらなくちゃいけないんだから
その一秒一秒やることに専心的に力を絞ってやればいいんです
だとすごい人生は気楽になるし
明るくもなるし 問題は解決する
このテーマができちゃったのは
やっぱり人が自分のことを棚に上げて
いつでも他人から完璧性を求めるという
とんでもない もう犯罪者だから
それは犯罪なんですよ
だから犯罪を起こしている人々の理屈を考えてみてください
同じ理屈なんですよ 自分にとって親切にしなかった
学校でちょっといじめられたんだ
それで閉じこもれてしまって
誰か殺さなくちゃあかんと
よくそういう理屈で考えるんだから
いじめられる原因 自分にあったかないかと
それはどうでもいいんです
自分のことは いじめに対して自分の対応が間違ったことは
いじめにあったら それを乗り越えればいいでしょうに
自分の問題だから それなりの何とかできるでしょうに
先生に言いなりに 警察に言うなりに
親に言うなりに 誰も聞かなかったら
もう紙でも書いていっぱい
私は何々さんで学校でいじめているんですけど
学校中そこらへんに書いて配ってしまえば
それで問題解決しますよ
簡単ですよ いっぱいコピー用紙持ってきて
あの コピーして 1,000万もう脅してもらったと
1,000万かかりませんでしょうに
もうもう 5,000円ぐらいあればあれぐらいのことできるでしょうに
じゃあできればこれからもやってみろと
だから頭ちょっと使えば
それなりになんとかね
先生も聞いてくれない
親も聞いてくれないと
警察に言っても馬鹿にされるんだと
だったらそれまで書いて
それも書いて あっちこっち
そうやっても何か方法はあるんですよ
だからそこでもう子供の対応が
自分の対応が間違ったことも気にしないで
やっぱりそいつらを殺さなくちゃいけないんだと
社会全体的にが間違っていると思ったりして
犯罪を起こしたりするでしょうに
それも結局 カンペカンペ主義者の問題なんですよ
だから この他人にいちいちいろいろ文句を言ったり
ケチをつけたり もういろんなことをしたりする世界
あのいろいろ事件を起こしている子供たちの心理と全く同じなんですね
思考パターンが だから私はもう何も遠慮しないで
このカンペ主義の思考っていうのは犯罪だと
自分のことを気にしないで
もう他人から完璧性完璧性を認めるということは
もう単なる単純犯罪ですよと
そこで自分のところでもとにかく完璧にやりたい
完璧にやりたいというのは
それは無知 完璧っていうのは成り立たないんだと
自分が自分の力いっぱい出せばそれで十分だと
結果比較したらどうでも比較した時点で間違ってるんだから
だからこの完璧主義のこのいい面もいい面は
私が言いたいのは無知
愚かさ 完璧主義の悪い面について私は言いたいのは
それは犯罪という答えなんです
この皆様も配って読み上げた
最初に読み上げた文章の中に
これを 2つに分けています
完璧主義はいい面で見れば
こういうこういうことで
几帳面で まあまあこういうことでは悪い面で見ればこういうことだなと 2つ分けているんですよ
いい面について私は完璧主義者に言いたいのは
アホ ただの無知 悪い面について言いたいのは
あんたは犯罪者ですと
だから無知も良くないし
犯罪者も良くないんだから
完璧主義っていうのは成り立たないもので捨てちゃえばいいんです
で どんどんどんどん全てのものはね
無常であるということに気づいてくると
すごく心が落ち着いて落ち着いて落ち着いてくる
ということで 一応まあ話は大体そこらそこら辺ぐらいでは終了したいんだけど
このもうちょっと余談なんですけど
完璧主義について考えたら
私は思い浮かんだ一つの例があったんですよ
あの あまり私は勉強していないんですけど
この西洋でこのクリスチャンサイエンスというふうな言葉ができちゃったんですね
で まあキリスト教文化の中からできた考え方であって
あるある宗教がね まあこのまあ既成的なキリスト教ではなくてね
まあいろいろカルト宗教団たくさん出ていますからね
キリスト教からは で 神は完全であると決める
で 神様は完全たる神様が不完全な世界は創造するはずがない
そこで神様が作ったこの世界は完全であると
故に この世の中にあるものは全部
どんな不幸でも どんな不公平なことでも
どうやって正当化するかと
それに頑張っちゃうんです
やり過ぎになっちゃって
もし人が病気になったら薬をあげる必要がない
それは神を侮辱することですと
そんな薬 点滴 点滴ですと言うんですか？それ
それから あれ 輸血 輸血する必要はありませんと
完璧に作っているんだから
お祈りさえすればいいと
というところまで持っていく
だからこの完璧主義っていうのはろくな結果にならないということだけ言いたいんですよ
あの人々は自分のカルト宗教はサイエンスと名付けているんだけど
サイエンスでも何でもないんですよ
まあ理屈だけですよ なぜかというと
神は完全でなければ いい加減な不完全なものだったら創造はできないだろうと
できないですね だろうではなくて
で だから創造したものも完全ですと
故に この世の中でみんないちいち言ってる病気やらいろんなことはあるはずがないと
よく論理的に来た説も結論ですね
だからあんなもう屁理屈もいいところで
そこでまあそんなにあまり扱ってはぐらいの例ではないんだけど
神は完璧ですとどうやって言えるんですかね
見たことも聞いたこともあったこともないんないのに
で どこかの人が言った話でしょうに
どこかの本に書いていることだけでしょうに
それに乗せられちゃって
みんなに迷惑をかけて
結構人死んじゃったんですよ
そういうカルトのおかげで
逆に仏教から見ると 世の中は不完全で不公平で
納得いかない 何を見ても
だからみんな頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
やっと生きてるだけなんですよ
それにはそれはそうじゃないと人が好き勝手に言いたくても
事実は事実なんです 生まれた赤ちゃんがそのまま放っておいちゃうと死んじゃうんです
たとえ完璧な神に作られたと思ったっても
じゃあ放っておかないで
ただおっぱいだけあげるということにしましょう
あげて まあなんとかご飯を食べるとこ食べられるところになっちゃったら放っておく
それでうまくいきますかね
何から何までも教えてあげなくちゃいけない
本人もすごく苦労して頑張らなくちゃいけない
人間っていうのは放っておいちゃうと言葉も喋れないでしょ
手も足も使えないんですよ
猿とチンパンジーと何の変わりもないんです
本当は我々は放っておけばチンパンジーになるはずでしたけどね
すごい苦労して頑張ってるんだから
こういう風な文化的な世界を作ってるんですよ
だから努力しなきゃ 頑張らなかったら何にも得られない世界
何の幸福も得られない世界
それはお釈迦様の見方
何にしたってもすごい努力
努力しないと 平和でいるために
ものすごく努力しないと平和にならないんですよ
逆に戦争するためにも同じことなんですよ
怠けちゃったらダメです
死ぬだけで終わっちゃうんです
平和にしたっても みんな活発的に行動しないと
人類が仲良くするようにと
いろんな意見 合わないところは全部全部まとめてまとめて頑張らないと平和にはならない
すごく努力しないと経済成長にはならない
そういうことだから お釈迦様は人間の努力ということ
精進ということ それは大変な大事な宝物として見ているんです
善として見ているんです
もし宗教の誰でも この人間の精進
努力を否定しちゃうと
お釈迦様はその宗教には真っ向から反対する
それだけはよしてことです
どんなくだらんことを言ってもいいんだけど
精進努力をやめることだけは教えないでくださいと
お釈迦様は心配で心配で
ただすべて神様に作って
神様は決まっているんだから
もう全知全能で万能で
あんた方は困る必要は何もないんだといったら何もないんだから
やることは それは それだけはよしてくれと
すべて神様だと言ってもいいんだけど
人間は努力してくださいと一言だけ言ってほしいんですね
そうするとその教えが矛盾になりますが
やっぱりしょうがないんですね
ですから証拠ないものは仏教では認めませんだから
そういう点ではあまり立ち触ろうとしない
神の概念については 我々知っているのは
我々は頑張ったらその分が良くなるんだと
怠けたらその分が不幸になるんだということ
そういうことで そこで話を終了しますけど
一応まとめます 完全主義というのは成り立たないことで
見方によってすべてそのままで完全だということは言えます
それは見方というのは無常の論理と因果法則の教えに基づいて考えると
もうどんな現象でも百パーセントの結果を出しているんだから
それ以上認めてはいけません
なぜそれ以上認めてなるかというと
人間の間違っている考え方で比べてみる
それは比べることもありえないことで
もし完璧主義になったと思ったら
その人は邪見を持っていて
すべてのものは無常で変化しているんだということを否定しようとしている
ありえないことで だから苦労だけになってしまっちゃうんだと
そういうぐらいのことで
我々は自分の力だけ精一杯出しちゃえばいいんじゃないかなということと
それから世の中から我々はあなた完全になれ
あなた完全になれとは頼んではいけませんだけど
仕事の場合はある仕事は完全にやってくれと
完璧に ある仕事は失敗したってもういいわ
もうやり直してもう一回やってくださいと頼めばいいところもあるし
そういうふうに世の中のことは分析してみるという内容でした
どうもありがとうございます